Це місто для життя, воно тихе, спокійне.
Тут люди щиріші, якщо до тебе хтось буркає,
то ти знаеш як він до тебе відноситься.
Але якщо він до тебе посміхається, то він щиро це робить.
Мені дуже радісно що до кого я не звертаюсь,
всі мені відповідають українською мовою.
Раніше такого не було,
раніше вони говорили російською.
Такі спеціально танцювальні,
з м'якої шкіри підошви.
Я люблю міксувати чаї,
це я вже заварив з усіляких трав.
Зараз я покажу, у мене тут є запаси.
Це чебрець.
А це річна м'ята.
Вона особлива, коли на сплавах
на байдарках буваю, заготовляю її.
Вона на таких острівцях посеред річки росте.
І вона дуже соковита та ароматна.
Тут ще черний чай  ще є,
він червонуватий трохи.
Чай гарний, заварився.
Вафлі — це колись в дитинстві
були мої найулюбленіші солодощі.
Мені здавалося що це найкраще,
що може приготуватися.
А потім уже дорослим, то собі вафель не купували.
А цього разу, думаю можу дати собі послаблення.
Мені подобаються маленькі міста,
мені подобаються Суми.
Я їзжу, коли тепло, на велосипеді.
І я можу за 15 хвилин доїхати в центр,
хоч і живу за містом.
Мені подобається що за день,
я можу вирішити купу справ,
фізично зустрівшись з людьми,
чого я не можу зробити в Києві чи Харкові.
Я туди приїзжаю по справах,
то я не встигаю, це не мій ритм.
Мені прикольно, бо тут спогади,
це моє маленьке, зручне для мене місто.
Трохи буде легше.
[ввімкнув вентилятор]
Закінчив консерваторію,
хотів викладати в музичному училищі.
Тут була робота.
А оскільки в той час побрався з сумчанкою,
то переїхав в Суми.
Львів — культурне місто, воно мене зростило.
Воно мене привчило до того,
що кожну суботу і неділю
були концерти, філармонії,
і ми відвідували ті концерти.
Тому коли я переїхав в Суми,
то я тут виховував музикантів в музичному училищі.
Але коли у мене з'явився фах органіста,
то я хотів це місто будити в суботу і неділю.
Так само робити органні концерти,
тому що в неділю тут люди відпочивали.
«Отдихали», як вони вони кажуть.
Суми дуже розслаблюють.
Тут є куди піти просто погуляти.
Це таке досить таки повільне,
досить зелене таке місто.
І тому потрібно відчувати, що ти в Сумах,
мобілізуйся, інакше зробиш, менше, ніж хотів би.
Це моє робоче місце.
У мене є старий комп'ютер,
на якому я набираю тест.
Він не підключений до інтернету.
Бо інтернет — великий ворог набирання тестів.
Я тоді зачиняю шторами вікно, і вмикаю [комп'ютер].
До речі, десь поділася настольна лампа.
Я вмикаю, і наче в якійсь норі сиджу,
і дуже затишно працювати.
Дуже люблять наші сумчани Бахівський фестиваль.
Якщо вони не бачать афіш,  як ідемо  по місту,
то я іду і мене зустрічають і питають:
«Де наш Бахівський фестиваль?
Чи буде Бахівський фестиваль?»
Такого фестивального не було,
в той час коли я приїхав сюди.
Фестивалі народилися у мене від того що,
я сам повинен був організовувати собі концерти.
Я навчився цій справі, і вирішив
це зробити для своїх колег та друзів,
і так народились фестивалі.
«Organum» [органум] — це є фестиваль органної,
камерної та джазової музики.
Потім джазовий фестиваль з'явився 1994 року.
А всі останні фестивалі ми робили благодійні.
І ми перераховували кошти,
вірніше, я приносив кошти від квитків
в благодійний фонд «Суми»,
на реабілітацію поранених бійців.
Деякі музиканти з Києва заангажовані,
їх запрошують в різні проєкти, вони відмовляються.
Якщо Суми звучать, вони відразу кажуть,
що ми не поїдемо в Суми.
А сумська публіка найбільш така рафінована.
Тому що вона слухає музику Баха
в правильній інтерпретації.
Тому якщо хтось буде грати
не в бароковому стилі,
сумчани відразу скажуть,
що це не бароковий музикант.
Головний наш проєкт,
по якому нас знають в Сумах, в Україні,
навіть за її межами, — це фестиваль
«Sumy Extreme Style» [Суми Екстрім Стайл].
Також це день вуличної музики Суми.
Фестиваль вуличного танцю по брейкингу
та хіп-хопу — Дій денс фестиваль.
Графіті — Дій графіті [фестиваль].
Люди коли займаються спортом,
(а це спорт перш за все)
вони дисциплінують себе,
і це допомагає потім в житті.
Вони бачать, що такі звичайні люди,
може трохи доросліші зробили цей фестиваль,
що вони в п'ятьох теж можуть
зробити якусь ініціативу.
І вони створюють, я вважаю, гарний вплив.
Тому ми набираємо волонтерів,
навчаємо їх первинним навичкам,
знайомимо їх, перш за все, один з одним.
Молоді потрібно себе реалізовувати.
Якщо місто не буде надавати їм таких можливостей,
вони будуть реалізовувати себе по-іншому.
І це аж ніяк не буде позитивно.
До цього каталися де доведеться по місту:
Театр Щепкіна, бібліотека ім. Крупської,
безпосередньо міська рада,
ну де що знайшли, там і катались.
Це призводило до травм,
небажаних конфліктів з поліцією,
з іншими людьми.
Бо не було спеціалізованого місця,
де можна було б їм сказати: «Іди туди і катайся».
Я жив і мої батьки живуть досі в районі,
який називається Лука.
Це така околиця Сум.
З трьох боків оточена Пслом.
Куди б ти не пішов, рано чи пізно
вийдеш на берег, там купа пляжів.
Все дитинство влітку,
головні розваги —
це річка, велосипед і книжки.
Там біля будинка Чехова,
була одновповерхова будівля бібліотеки,
куди я був записаний.
Я пам'ятаю, що дуже гордився,
що в 13 років я вичитав всі там книжки.
І в 13 років постало питання: що робити далі?
І мама мене записала в дорослу бібліотеку.
Там така класна будівля,
там хороший був бібліотечний фонд.
І там уже я читав до інституту, довго туди ходив.
І на якосмусь етапі, до мене прийшла в голову думка,
так про це я багато читаю,
так може спробувати написати.
І я почав та написав одне оповідання,
друге оповідання, і це затянуло.
Я думав треба вирішити я письменник чи ні.
Напишу роман значить письменник,
якщо ні, то не письменник.
Я сидів по 10 годин на день і писав.
І я написав, і сказав собі,
все Влад — роман написаний, ти письменик.
І все. Тоді уже, в кінці літа 1998 року
я зрозумів, що я письменник.
Зрозумів, що більше немає
про що мріяти, так і залишився.
Якогось такого окремого літературного
життя в Сумах, на жаль, немає.
Але ж такі як, наприклад, у пані Ірини Проценко,
тут сьогодні музиканти збираються,
завтра хтось там читає свої вірші
чи читає прозу, я там читав своє оповідання.
Гарне це місце, енергетичне, спокійне.
Музиканти, художники, фотографи,
поети, письменники,
люди, які щось хочуть робити, щось творять.
То вони хочуть поділитися цим,
то вони мають тут аудиторію, місце.
Вони мають тут публіку близько.
Вони сидять тут навколо.
Це зовсім інший формат.
Це, перш за все, душевне спілкування,
«квартирники», як у нас кажуть.
Все відбувається на природі,
і це дуже зворушливо.
До революції це був парк Лещинських,
потім після революції
його назвали на честь Кожедуба.
А всі так називають його, просто парк.
І ось зараз якщо придивитися,
то попереду видно фігуру,
і там, до речі, хтось контактує
з Антоном Павловичем [Чеховим].
Сидить хтось на руках у нього.
Чехов — це одна із таких легенд Сум,
які намагаються розвивати.
У нас тут є кілька легенд —
це партизани, цукор,
бо свого часу місто будувалось коштом
цукрових магнатів Харитоненків.
І Чехов.
Як видно, найбільшою популярністю
користуються коліно та рука
Антона Павловича [Чехова].
Не зацілований.
Ось так можна тут в обіймах
с Антоном Павловичем поспілкуватись.
Прошу увагу на цитату:
[російською] «Аббація і Адріатичне море чудові,
але Лука і Псел краще».
Це для сумського патріотизму такий плюс.
Я почав чути більше рідної мови,
сам почав розмовляти українською.
Я впевнений, що війна
дала на нас свій відбиток.
З'явилися люди, які були там,
для яких Україна — це не просто слово,
не просто вишиванка,
не просто наш прапор,
це щось більше.
Це твоє ДНК.
І ти хочеш, навіть якщо поїдеш
з цієї країни, щоб воно було с тобою.
Щоб ти був носієм цієї культури.
І коли ти вітаєшся в інших країнах,
то ти кажеш: «Я з України».
І люди питають, що це,
і ти можеш відповісти.
Тому я впевнений, що ми змінились
в більшості своїй.
Ті музиканти українські, які приїзжають,
вони кажуть: «Ми приїжджаємо так,
як приїхали в Німеччину, Австрію, словом, в Європу».
Я їх зустрічаю з поїзда.
І вони не мають ніяких побутових проблем.
Вони мають повні зали,
це найголовніше для них.
Кажуть, що ми їдемо в Суми ніби як в Європу.
Ми працюємо з цільовими аудиторіями.
Творча інтелегенція ходить.
Ми працюємо з дітьми,
потім вони приходять і кажуть:
«Ви знаєте, колись мене мама
привела за руку сюди в 1990-х роках.
26 років пройшло [з того моменту].
А зараз я привожу своїх дітей».
Розумієте, ось і молода аудиторія.
Я нав'язував їм свої смаки,
я нав'язував їм своє бачення інтерпретації.
Я їх інфікував музикою Баха.
Деякий час ми жили з дружиною
і їздили в Німеччину.
І ми розмовляли, та кажемо: «Мабуть, коли
нам буде по років 80, нам треба сюди приїздити».
Все спокійно, всі все знають.
Але ж немає ніяких перепон,
немає з чим боротися, кого перемагати.
А тут постійно якісь вороги,
все щось потрібно лагодити,
щось тут комусь допомогти.
Тому ми полюляємо рух,
ми полюбляємо Україну,
бо Україна — це зміни.
А насправді дуже величезні можливості є.
Та якщо ними скористатися,
то можна досягати величезних речей,
яких в жодній країні не буде.